thank you and we are here with one of
the victors of today's round maxine
bashar lagarov welcome to zagreb great
way to kick off the tournament yeah
friends is i think doing well very well
two out of two for the french team here
in zagreb take us a little bit through
what happened in your game it seemed
like you just took the initiative from
the get-go
not really like i'm not happy with what
i did in the opening like
it's night a697 it's not here of course
it's when the knight is on d2
and here of course i'm worse like
i want queen d to f5 but of course
summers but dtx6
made me think like i was
getting away with it and
yeah i just took the pawn and i'm
assuming i'm doing very well here
which is basically what happened so
um
like yeah f5 was a good move to
again take initiative straight on f4 and
yeah then it was more or less over
yeah it seemed that he fell apart
quickly after that of course we are a
little bit limited in time we have five
minutes into the next round but we have
to ask you we have to ask everybody the
big news came out today what are your
feelings as a player that is
participating in the world championship
cycle yeah by then i was not surprised
anymore like at first i thought he would
play but uh in the last few days it was
clear magnus wouldn't play why made you
think that well what made it so clear um
well
basically you what was
being told you know in the
is a
sideshow yeah like
so internal um
internal sources internal sources so
anyway
i mean it's magnus decision like
for me it doesn't change
anything for now
now the question is of course
it will not
of course provoke a change of cycle
uh this time
but maybe for the next cycle actually so
then
things was the best thing the best thing
is of course to get everyone at the
table uh magnus or the players to to
think about what we want
i mean it could be that we don't change
anything but
um you know it's a pity of course when
uh as well number one and world champion
for 10 years
is not part of the cycle anymore so but
um
so we'll see in the next few years do
you feel that this being the crown jewel
of the chess world do you feel the match
is worth a little bit less now that the
number one player is not going to
participate
uh nice
i mean to be fully honest i thought it
was already worthless in the sense that
uh i think it's not adapted to to our
time so i thought there
are probably better ways of uh
designing the world champion
uh of course it's been tradition and a
lot of people don't agree with me on
that
that i know but
i still think that
it was maybe time for a change and maybe
this move by magnus will uh
will be a catholicist
well we certainly hope so i agree i love
rapid and blitz so i definitely agree
with you i would love i
didn't necessarily mean to switch to to
rapid and it's like there are other ways
other ways well we'll see if future
changes it up i know that you have a
game in a few minutes so we'll let you
go guys maximum sherlock graph starting
off excellently here
you